michel géminiani est un artiste discret
et pourtant quel parcours lauréat du
prestigieux prix de rome en 1966
professeur aux beaux-arts à paris durant
35 ans michel géminiani est aujourd'hui
installée ici en sologne
au coeur de cette nature au milieu de
ses couleurs de grandes sources
d'inspiration inspiration d'automne
lumière divers chatoiement de printemps
éclats de l'été les quatre temps de
michel géminiani se déploie et se
rejoignent une fresque gigantesque
célébration fulgurante de la vie et des
paysages sologny je suis tombé à nouveau
de cette nature qui est à la fois
sauvage
malgré tout on la décrit trop comme
quelque chose d'assez obscur là ces
fouilles et c'est moi je trouve que
c'est joyeux
sa fraise que la dernière de ses oeuvres
michel géminiani là imaginer ici chez
lui dans son atelier au coeur de la
sologne raconter des histoires de fleurs
de marennes nénuphars de des tas de
choses qui sont près de nous et qu'on
regarde pas forcément avec la tension
mettions des des débordements coloré
d'un imaginaire
peut-être un peu chez moi outrancier
mais festif c'est une est un passage
festif de la nature et l'art de michel
géminiani est une figuration allusive
comme le clame et paul cézanne
il s'agit pour lui non pas imiter la
nature mais d'en restituer le processus
c'est une plume mais à aucun moment ça a
été fait avec un petit pinceau il des
petits trucs tu as été fait avec mon
pouce regarder cela c'est comme ça que
l'est pas j'ai mis du blanc là je puisse
fais pas ma plume comme ça c'est un plus
29 le point de plus voilà la magie
pictural de michel géminiani le très
spontané qui va à l'essentiel
un art qui pense le monde par des actes
simples la sensibilité avant tout
du théâtre burlesque indigné dans un
décor télé cartonné la compagnie
zigomatik propose le grand jeu de la fin
une pièce engagée qui parle de
mondialisation et de crise alimentaire
bienvenue dans la civilisation du hors
sol dans l'industrie de la bouffe
bienvenue dans la révolution de l'humour
au service de l'humain c'est à voir au
22 d'auron
ibrahim maïga et sa troupe de danseurs
sont à tours samedi soir du spectacle
plein les yeux réalisé par le
chorégraphe ex petit ami de madonna du
hip hop de la valse du cha cha le tout
accompagné d'un orchestre live un bel
aperçu du talent multiforme que brahim
zaibat
quand le cirque rencontrent la poésie il
n'est pas encore minuit c'est le titre
du nouveau spectacle de la compagnie xy
une vingtaine d'acrobates et de
voltigeur des instants plein de peps
d'autres plus mélancolique à découvrir à
l'équinoxe
si vous êtes du côté de chartres le
compas présente l'exposition les carte
et le territoire
l'évolution de la cartographie du
département euréliens du xviie siècle à
nos jours
instructif en plein débat sur la réforme
territoriale
enfin ne manquez pas 400 trees le groupe
de pop rock toulousain est au château
d'eau jeudi soir
est ce un jeu
il
voilà sachez aussi que bd boum s'est
ouvert ce matin le 31e festival de la
bande dessinée s'installe tout le week
end à la halle aux grains de blois
nous y reviendrons dans nos éditions de
demain et puis nous on se dit ah la
semaine prochaine pour de nouvelles
idées sorties bon week end